welcome
everyone thank you for joining us for
today's presentation
titled comparison of pam50 intrinsic
subtype profiles
in match primary and metastatic breast
cancer
samples from the ctc mbc clinical trial
it is my pleasure to introduce to you
professor
lisa ryden she's a full professor
in surgery at lund university in sweden
and also a senior consultant in general
surgery
at scan university hospital for a
complete
biography on our speaker please visit
the tab at
the top of your screen if any questions
arise
during her presentation we encourage you
to submit these questions
in the q a box and our speaker
after the presentation will respond back
to you by email
please join me in welcoming professor
lisa ryden
he will i will now turn the presentation
over to her
so welcome today's presentation from
lund university
and you can see the beautiful blossoming
tree
in front of here and i'm going to
present
a comparison of pam1526 subtype profiles
in matched primary metastatic breast
cancer samples from the cdc
embassy trial and my name is elisa rudin
and i'm a full professor at luna
university
and this is a short presentation of me
and to begin with i will declare that i
have no conflict of interest
to this in relation to this presentation
and i have some different focus areas
and
this one will adhere to the tumor
progression
[Music]
research program
and the outline of the speech i will
give a short
background with a couple of slides the
implication of tuna progression
in breast cancer and for clinical care
i will present the study design of this
trial
and the objectives and most importantly
the results of the study
and some future aspects as well
so i will start with a background slides
and you might be familiar with the tumor
progression concept
and it has gone from linear progression
meaning that the tumor inherits changes
linearly by time in contrast to
the parallel progression model where
there might be
similar existing clones
even in the same tumor that might give
rise
to parallel metastatic clones
and you can see the cartoon from
poliak's
keynote paper in 2014
illustrating this the coexisting
or existence of parallel clones
where those having a survival advantage
will expand in the metastatic site
and in the clinical setting we do know
that
endocrine sensitive tumors not
always respond to endocrine therapy
and it has been a key issue whether this
is related
to primary endocrine resistance or
whether this is developed
over time under pressure of systemic
therapy
and there's a little knot here you might
have
the biomarker exploration of the
synchronous lymph node which
have not has not been exposed to any
systemic therapy
whether this can explain the
therapy resistance in the primary
setting
and you remember
speaking about tumor progression between
primary tumors
and synchronous lymph node metastasis
and i want to tell you that there have
been quite a few
papers presenting data from small
retrospectives
series showing a discordance in
single biomarker expression between
primary tumors and synchronous lymph
node metastasis
as well as a discordance
in the thyroid subtypes
however these discordances
are not translated into prognosis
so we have no clinical benefit
either to to test the biomarker
expression
in the nodal metastasis
in contrast it's well established
that it's well worth making the
biomarking
you know typing of distant metastases
several papers since the mid-20s
has shown that there are several
a clinically important changes towards a
more aggressive phenotype
in the metastasis and it's typically a
loss
of er expression
and this has also been related to
the worst prognosis for post-relapse
outcome and by now treatment guidance by
phenotype in distance
this is well established
so whenever you can access a biopsy
you should have a phenotyping on that
routine phenotyping or needle biopsies
and metastatic breast cancer was
introduced in sweden
already in 2014 and there are several
other international guidelines
supporting this
notion so what do we
know about the intrinsic subtypes of
distant metastases
we now have some data on it
although not all confusing
there is one um publication
actually from sweden from 2017
uh showing that the intrinsic subtypes
were prognostic also for post relapse
breast cancer survival
however this the presented cohort
also included primary locally
advanced tumors along with distant
metastases so it's
more or less a mixed cohort
and then another important
piece of paper is from cevallion from
the same year when they
collected 123
patients 102 samples comparing
primary tumors and distant metastases
they could confirm the prognostic
influence by pamphlet
subtyping in primary tumors
albeit not prognostic from distant
metastases
and there are some ongoing trials the
large aurora
initiative which is scheduled to include
1 000 patients and we also have a local
one
in sweden the primary end
point in aurora according to clinical
trials is
metastatic breast cancer understanding
and i have not seen any definitive
results here i think it's ongoing
and both of these these are collecting
fresh
tissue
so then let's go into the
present study and the present study is
based on the prospective
observational trial which was initially
launched
as a monitoring trial for
circulating markers and most importantly
circulating tumor cells but also some
serum and plasma markers and
we also from the beginning scheduled an
extensive translational
protocol including subtyping
on formally fixed embedded tissue
and most of them had hormone responsive
disease
some were too enriched and some were
triple negative
and for this study we had two
aims we wanted to collect
all what we could get and it was
primary tumors synchronous lymph node
metastasis
for patients being lymph node positive
and also or
biopsies from distant metastases
to make the descriptive comparison and
also the prognostic value of the
subtyping
between two more sites
and here is a busy flow chart the
original study cohort was
106 and then we executed 12
12 not fulfilling the inclusion criteria
and we ended up with 156 patients
and with them applied for
biobank material sweden is quite
unique that we collect all formally
fixed
tissue in regional biobanks
and all our all researchers are allowed
to have access to this material after
ethical
and biobank approval
so we collected from three different
buyer banks because this was
my multi-site study
and we ended up with less than these 156
of course so we had 110
paired samples from primary tumors and
distant metastases and 54
would triplets and
the tissue was sectioned and
microdissected
and the rna as well as dna i was
isolated from the tissue and run
at our local laboratory at
middle university at the northern
spring profiler
and the pen 50 assignment was done
by non-string technologies
and this is the initial results
as you see we had 140
with initial samples for this
and you can look at the primary tumor
where you see an abundance on the
luminal a
the dark blue is luminal a
the bright blue is luminar b
and the pink one is turquoise and the
red one is pass alike
so from the beginning it was a
predominance on luminal a tumors
which was diminished already to the
lymph node metastasis
and even to a larger extent in distant
metastasis
and on note is the enrichment
of the her2 enriched in the dissonant
metastasis
and here is a comparison of the
subtyping in primary tumors and lymph
node metastasis
as well as from the pancreatic the
subtype in primary tumors
and distant metastases and
if we start with a comparison with a
lymph node metastasis
you can see that already here there is a
skewness
we have tested for aluminum a versus
non-luminal
a using the exact magnema test
and also exact test of symmetry across
all subclasses and although both of them
were highly significant
but you can see the most prominent shift
here
is from the luminal a subtype in the
primary tumor
towards the luminal b in the lymph node
metastasis but there are also shifts
in the other direction
moving on to the comparison in between
primary tumors and distant metastases
you find a different
view there is still a highly discordance
in between these sides but
what is prominent here is that there is
a significant shift
from lumen and a of not only going to
luminal b but also to her to enriched
ambassador like
and of these 52 luminal-like
tumors we had 12 of them
moving towards a non-luminal subtype
so it's quite a busy
slide but take a moment just to look at
the shifts here
on the other hand the her2 enriched was
stable from primary tumor to the
distant metastasis
and here are the kaplan myer plots
here from primary tumors lymph node
metastasis
and distant metastases and we also
included
the cox modeling univariable and
multivariable
and for the data from primary tumor
we have strong evidence
that conflict subtyping is prognostic
for progression free survival
and progression free survival was the
primary endpoint and
it was from time of diagnosis of
metastatic disease
to progression and it
was also strongly prognostic uh
adjusting
for all co-variants which bedard
presented in his model
looking at the lymph node metastases
they look
quite similar when you see the
kaplan plot however it was
suggestive of an evidence that it was
prognostic
and moving on to the distant metastasis
it had some sign of prognostic
information
but this was not as evident as in the
primary tumor and lymph node metastasis
and i will just share with you a small
case report
and it was a person
operated upon in
2007 and
she had no positive disease
and we collected the tumor tissue both
from the primary tumor and lymph node
metastasis
and you can see that she is quite
representative
from the cartoons you had seen
that even in the synchronous lymph node
metastasis there was a shift from a
to b then she recurred and had
a local region and recurrence in 2014
which was her2
enriched and then
unfortunately she
have progressed already the same year
and was deceased
one year later and this lady
had five years of endocrine therapy
which was routine by that time and she
also had
her two directed therapy directed
to that
so my conclusion is that the pam50
breast cancer interesting
subtype was not stable throughout
tumor progression there was strong
evidence that there is a shift
towards a more aggressive subtype
and we saw a shift from towards a
non-luminance
subtype both between primary tumors and
lymph node metastasis and between
primary tumors and distant metastases
and these were a bit
different changes from the
primary tumor to the lymph node
metastasis
was in between luminal a to luminance b
still luminar tumors whereas from the
primary tumors to distant metastases
we also diagnosed
patients going from fewer luminal tumors
to non-aluminum tumors including
quite a few her2 enriched ones
we could confirm the prognostic value of
pump 50
breast cancer subtypes of the primary
tumor
but we were not then able to demonstrate
a similar strong prognostic value
at the other tumor sites
and i have just made a slide here from
the values presentation because i think
it's interesting
that these both public publications are
quite
similar and they also had a predominance
of luminal a
and found that they had a
large fraction of her two enriched
tumors
in the descent metastasis
and here's the forest plot clearly shown
in the prognostic
the added prognostic value of the
intrinsic subtypes
from the primary tumor but for these
in the distant metastases they all cross
the zero line there
and what's next
this whole project was
aimed to capture all the bc 360 data
so we are curious waiting for them we
have the 1050 sub typing
which is good enough but i think the v6
pc 360 will surely add
important information in the field here
and as i mentioned we also extracted dna
so we are scheduling a
mutational analysis along this
and it will be a broad panel of
foundation one life panel
and thank you for your attention
here's my group and the lady behind this
shallot teacher whom is the first
author along with amilosha
are the most important persons
behind this word so thank you
so professor ryden very nice
presentation
one particular question that i had is
what is the future
for pam50 shop typing in metastatic
samples
while not adding convincingly prognostic
information where do you see
the value of this intrinsic biology in
this context in the metastatic disease
well thank you for putting that question
i don't think the last conclusion can be
made about the pam-50 self-typing in
distant metastasis
we have at the moment there might be
more
two publications or two different
cohorts
from this value and the one
presented here and it's still
only less than 200 samples
so i don't think you can make a
definitive conclusion
and i don't know whether the pan-50
subtype being
is a good choice for metastatic biopsies
you know the algorithm was trained
for in the advanced setting towards
the survival from primary diagnosis
and from diagnosis of primary disease
to recurrence so i think
if you should have a pump 54 in the
metastatic disease
i think you will have to make a new
algorithm
training towards progression or post
relapse survival and
so i don't know i think we all should
pool
our data once we have
a larger common cohort
another question that i had is which
particular therapy did the patients
receive
in this ctc mbc trial
was it chemotherapy targeted therapy or
combinations
could you please specify the different
therapies they received
yes the ctc embassy trial as you said
it was
an easy-going design and not that easy
going because we
only included patients at their
first diagnosis of metastatic disease
before receiving any systemic therapy
and so that was the tricky thing just
to find these first time relaxes
um and the easygoing thing
is that any clinically
routine systemic therapy
was allowed so you saw that most of the
patients were
endocrine responsive at the time of
metastatic disease
so we i think we had less than half
started on hormonal therapy most of them
started
on chemotherapy and some on
her2 targeted therapy for those being
her2 amplified at time of metastasis
so it was really a pragmatic trial
in addition another question that i had
is could you please
elaborate a little bit more on the
significant shift
of the subtypes from primary tumors to
lymph nodes
metastasis do you think it is worth
testing
both primary and synchronous lymph node
metastasis do you think it would give us
more information and if so what type of
information would you expect
and what type of clinical decisions you
would think
you could eventually with validation you
could
get out of it
and for the lymph node metastasis it's
more
research interest on how
is this progression
from the primary tumor to lymph nodes
mirrored
in tumor characteristics of the
metastatic cells in the lymph node i
don't think it
will ever have any large
clinical implication but it it should
definitely be
a key subject for further research along
with
phenotyping of the new competent cells
in the lymph node metastasis it could
give out as some
insights into the progress
of the disease but
in the clinical setting it's important
to remember
that it does retain prognostic
information
and if you don't have any tumor material
from the breast you can always make
your sampling from lymph node metastasis
and
european or and maybe demon typing of it
and finally one question also that i had
is can you speculate
on the aurora trial and its role in
guidance for genomic testing
in metastatic tissue in the future
and then the aurora trial and we have a
sibling in sweden called this can be
wrecked
yes that's a very ambitious project
and i have not any definitive
insight in it but i think it's going to
be
designed mainly to be able to guide
patients into clinical trials
and a large step towards that is
the mutational panels i don't know if
they are doing foundation one
on all of them and as far as i remember
you can be including
whatever cycle you are on so it
it has a different perspective but it's
definitely
important and i think it's one
important step also towards
implementation
of taking biopsies
and sampling fresh tissue
so once this trial
or study is finalized you will have
taught to the whole of you
how to sample this
tissue and that i'm looking forward
to see anything concrete out of it
and the learned trials can be a wreck
it has a local trial but
even when they do
will collect formalin fixed tissue but
it's uh on hold by now
due to the complete situation
so to conclude this presentation we have
presented can
50 subtyping from primary tumors lymph
node metastasis
and distant metastases and convincingly
convincingly shown a
significant shift towards a more
aggressive subtype
in the metastasis and we could also
confirm
the prognostic value of m50 subtyping
from primary tumors also translated into
progression-free survival
whereas the survival data from 150
subtyping
in metastatic tissue was
a weak evidence
and i would like to thank you for your
attention